hey guys it's Gary Vaynerchuk it welcome
to episode 1 of trash talk
Josh you're confused my friends I'm a
winner you root for winners dick yeah
where I talk about trash and the flip
life of how you take that trash and turn
it into my favorite view in the world AJ
and I like 13 years ago started this
blog called trash talk
we've recorded one episode we never
aired it and just documenting the
process of buying and flipping it's 7:33
in the morning right now we're on our
way to Nutley New Jersey 8 a.m. town
wide sale the biggest thing I look for
in a garage sale game which is a little
less scalable than let's say go into
thrift stores or buying things online
and flipping them is a town-wide sales
that's where the entire town gives
permits or permission for people to have
garage sales and so you're able to hit
30 40 50 60 70 garage sales in 2 or 3
hours makes it much more efficient d-roc
is now accompanying me huh it's like our
fifth show together in Iraq
trash talk episode 1 Nutley New Jersey
on our way let's go see what we can find
yeah little loser there yeah I'm here
how's it look do they look good there's
not a lot out understood early bird gets
the [ __ ] worm
I'll see in a few minutes five minutes
south on River Road toward our cabinet I
think about garage sale that really
turns me on is the thrill of the hunt
because it's the place where you can
really score a huge box of toys for
three bucks worth 300 I just got three
mugs the big big killing me right now is
I can't really look these things up and
show you because I gotta get more stuff
this is the early bird kind of moment so
this three or four right now buddy they
get these three mugs the WWF stuff is
freshest [ __ ] and we'll see how much
it's worth in a minute all right let's
go
just put into your phones on listen
potential gold everywhere
[Music]
nothing here at all just another waste
of 7-8 minutes
key moments in the early game that you
don't want to waste unbelievably cold
start that place had some stuff that we
really looked at it like what the Giants
hoodie baby think you can probably get
30 for that it's like retro vintage you
go to like hipster Ville and Brooklyn
you go you put that on Etsy and put like
1980s Giants baby hoodie clothes and be
like there's two all right I'm feeling
good about this this doesn't look good
I'll be ready now
[ __ ] it was in out here what losing
first of nineveh's Astra's disastrous
here my carry on you nearly 400 don't
need that much that 15 bucks 30 bucks
I don't know usually you usually truly
you only need about a hundred bucks you
know if you're going yeah yeah I mean
I'm trying to pump try a lesser a dollar
out here for how do you think I'm trying
to pay two dollars this is about to be
bad
ice cold yeah boy this is not off to a
good start
this could be a visa looks a little too
new but we're about the [ __ ] strike
they're striking to be done here
[Music]
I'm not sure to stuff the animals 50
cents good bunch mom Amy
how much is this alright stuff the
animals continue to be my score fifty
cents a pop Dumbo Disney Store
snuffleupagus bang Olaf what and this
one's gonna be a beast the fao schwarz
fao schwarz giraffe
now now
no it's not why not because it just
isn't just look at the face what that
one looks chatter no look at the patches
on the eyes like it's not the one Oh
weird it's just was it Russell on the
other day it does yeah so it is the fao
schwarz
Jeffery really yeah
it's definitely well it's the $30 one so
we just hooked it up the the Jeffery
giraffe Toys R Us FAO Schwartz combo 30
bucks to pay 50 cents and I'm nice to
say after eBay fees just like a quick 20
bucks just a lot of people not making 20
bucks an hour like just one of the
things wait till I look up to
snuffleupagus FAO Schwartz was a very
famous toy store in New York anything
FAO Schwartz is always gonna hit at 50
cents period end of story
you know themes and you know pop culture
so much of the stuff that I care about
with nostalgia comes from my early
garage-sale days I'm sure because happy
days and Three's Company and Reese's
Pieces and totally the tiger and just
like nostalgia pop culture like I'm just
I'm just like I'm like one with pop
culture which is why I was good at
garage selling pre looking up [ __ ] on
phone that's why like I'm gonna trends
and like I just really deeply deeply
entrenched in like human interests and
behaviors and things they like and
things they react to and just plays out
in so many different ways this guy's
gonna be like what the hell is going on
yeah you turn on a pole
yeah u-turns are illegal driving is
really at the core of garage saleing if
you're not willing to legally drive and
you might as well you might as well not
come out very good buy more than enough
animal yeah I'm very good Kenai for like
which producers and which pop-culture
items there's some spongebob stuff that
I could debate it but other than that I
feel pretty good about what I took of
what I left I see at the rock this guy's
killing me
it's got literally walking in the middle
road slowed me down people putting up
signs and [ __ ] I'm trying to just win
out here I feel like there's something
here about the way I see it there they
look like oh jeez they know what they're
doing I have a feeling me
[Music]
[Music]
thank you my friend thank you have a
good day you two know all about the mugs
today this Starbucks mug 2010 snowflake
mug see what's up for a dollar
shouldn't ago she ate it 50 cents but
wasn't in the mood doesn't look good
it's sold for two bucks paid a dollar
for a mug it's worth - I want to punch
someone
we'll be supporting that 25 cent man
I'll take a cup buddy
one cup please I'll keep a change you're
welcome you're welcome
gotta support the original hustle you
know what I mean look at the pouring
skills the extra lemons in this bowl is
really good marketing you know what I
mean caught my eye good job you're
welcome
this one looks bougie I tend to do bad
with bougie sales this bougie as [ __ ]
thank you
we are ice-cold I'm not happy about it
what's this I got excited
morning how are you good have a great
day so high scold right now it's so
ice-cold trash talk I'm very upset at
least when you read content reading
ice-cold is okay I'm like Starks Game
six Tuesday
[Music]
all right make a right here okay let's
go low yeah loo that that did something
for me an area where we can feel good
you know I'm gonna I'm gonna post the
supposed to video I'm Instagram let's
take a minute
stunt poster really who didn't know I
did all this I post every single thing
right every single word on on hand
hygiene Twitter every day
thank you so much is that this is pretty
exciting to me
the vintage Lego thing never opened out
2003 Jesus I'm getting old but still 15
years old excited to open this up this
was a huge score I already looked it up
paid 3 they wanted 5 paid 3 for these
spider-man skates in package never
opened as well or opened pretty excited
about it
oh don't worry that's so awesome right
all right let's go she goes at least go
around the corner pull me so good so
good
Lego four zero nine eight twenty five
bucks give it to me little all right pay
two bucks for this all right cool
I really hope you picked up on her under
voice
look left this one has huge potential
the wind's coming out I like what I'm
seeing here Big Bear close there's some
stuff going on here the size of it
Apple status is the best degree Pikachu
okay all right if he could shoot Pokemon
put it in the bank all day
Pokemon always flips demand is real so
some may see snow globes in there and
they are better than I think I thought
did you do ten if I bought three yeah
okay we have a bag I do have a bag
awesome
this is [ __ ] exciting we just bought
three snow globes for ten bucks
and I'm fired up I'm fired up my guy I'm
fired up all right how do you feel feel
really good now starting to get hot
getting some stuff now well over $200
range maybe a little bit more even feel
much better hold on when you need it I
like
it's probably more let's see let's go
I'll just feel like there could be
something here or not whole puzzle is
fun thank you
[Music]
thirty-five bugs are out bikes are
outdoorsy all right now the world is
waking up whoa now that just how I like
Paul see another one over here let's get
let's get Gaul it's amazing
the third one looks like a zoo alright
now that I made 100 bucks in those snow
globes let's see there I'm fired up
we're followed you from your original
stuff no your original quality to
Mikhalkov the Geary name was dying oh
yes on Twitter what's up Gary my name is
Gary and I don't know if you've heard
but our name is in trouble it says -
would you take a dollar fist yeah thanks
alright picked up the scary bear for a
dollar called for real from Tiger 2004
let's see what it's worth
twenty bucks all day fix all day twenty
bucks
Kumi can I get more excited about this
than right
I like the carwash hustle alone okay I'm
gonna go real quick like 13 seconds
[Music]
[Music]
just picked up two jerseys for two bucks
apiece Kevin Durant Seattle SuperSonics
Jersey pretty rare two bucks
Garnett really nice one actually
stitched Celtics two bucks each
we'll say sixty four bucks for the
Durant I mean you know pay two bucks you
saw my there's a little bit like shitty
stains on it I can clean that off it's
just crazy how much your to stuff the
animals how much for the stuffed animals
okay Oh baby
to Disney scores 50 cents each have a
good day
stuffed animals all [ __ ] day trash
talk what's up P 50 cents each frozen
and inspired Bell Disney authenticated
this is a build-a-bear Anna again you
want to look for the Disney Store stuff
that stuff kills just look them both up
on eBay this is 17 all day this is 12
without the dress called 20 trash talk
I'm talking about 37 bucks for a dollar
just all day
I'm gonna put a kid to it home yeah take
care say well never collector you're
never a collector couple minutes ago I
knew nothing about cherish bears now I'm
a cherish bears expert huge score paid
24 a whole lot got about fourteen thirty
thirty regular bears and this sand set
I'm gonna look this up it's being a
crazy unbelievable yeah I've been doing
it for like four years
okay I love it it's so fun right oh my
god I could buy a brooch for 25 cents
and sell it for a hundred dollars on
Etsy on eBay on what I do eBay I do
Macari yeah my car he's really hot it's
really hot right now yeah next we're
good for you good luck keep doing it I'm
super mad at that lady because she took
half the stash because this could have
been huge so I love her for a hustle but
I'm mad that she was there one hundredth
of a second two dudes that took selfies
with me they were there they came back
after he looked it up cherish bear
[ __ ] cherish bear
if I was really doing this right just
hide me I'd make a thousand a week easy
and if you'd like on just Saturday just
working Saturday so look I mean I
genuinely think goodwill eBay buying
bulk on eBay selling animals like I just
think this is the hundred thousand
dollar a year thing there's so many
people making thirty to sixty thousand a
year if they've just like a passion and
love you saw how much she loved it woman
we got to show her that's the key to
trash-talk
the passion I feel phenomenal this is
the big final score it's about a hundred
bucks minimum and now I know about
cherish Teddy's now I'ma cherish Teddy's
player and every time you become more of
a player of a new thing look this is
very simple spent forty fifty per twenty
forty bucks 50 bucks easily now into the
five or six hundred dollar range of
resale I just wish so many of you would
do this it's four or five six hundred
bucks every weekend it's now 1147 so
we're four hours in little gas money I
get it but like net net two three four
hundred bucks every weekend and if you
don't want to be like tedious cuz now
you got a post in all this cool just
throw up this huge collection of cherish
Teddy's 80 bucks boom quick little you
know sixty bucks here [ __ ] adds up when
he got groceries when you got bills when
you got college loans when you got rent
people sitting around dwelling eighty
five ninety percent this country working
you know minimum wages low incomes it
just matters teaching people how to fish
live life it's real
time that they see how many days that
I've been season right now my mom always
told me just to go for it every time
they see me they say is what it is so
why you so mad at me last but there's so
many rappers that they all started
calling me